Should I take a binder on an empty stomach? So I'm binder so a binder is something
I was kind of alluded to that before I was talking about the seven phases of detoxification phase
Five in my book is
Grabbing onto stuff in the gut. So it stays in the gut
Well, eventually it's causing the toilet but stays in the gut and not reabsorbed
So you don't want to be a reabsorbed toxins. You want to reabsorb water in the last part of the large intestine
You want to be absorbing reabsorbied hormones estrogens or it was commonly reabsorbed by females in the last part of the larger
Tested the toxins that your liver work so hard to get rid of and dump into the small intestine can be reabsorbed
If your test especially if your intestinal transit time is slow and or you have
Tested a permeability issues me. You have leaky gut. So using a binder is
You know different whole of a guess sense humic acid
Different clays different. There's a lot of different binders on the market that are really good
That just grab onto things in the gut and binders typically will stay in the gut and hold things in the gut
So it can be deposited into the toilet
Should you take those on an empty stomach generally? Yes
Why why can't I just take them with that food because they can't buy minerals to so if you're getting your minerals through your food
They can be bound by those binders. We don't want to do that. So typically you take them about 30 to 60 minutes away from food
That's typically how you take binders